I want to ask you about this you tweeted
this a still is about Alexa I think we
have it what's what's going on here did
you did you buy Alexa no I don't know
why people would voluntarily bug your
own house
like do you think you're the only one
listening in on that you never saw weird
science how creepy these nerds are all
these cameras on your phone all of that
the people go on ancestry.com why would
you send you saliva into the internet
why would you do that why don't you just
go to the Illuminati and help them build
your robot replacement
[Applause]
I get if you're like african-american
you know yet they made them change the
names you don't know where you're from
but if you're white I just use this most
arrogant thing ever like you know what
you are basically don't you like hubs
fully yourself are you like I just have
to figure out this recipe because I am a
hoot 2% Portuguese I knew I like peppers
too much a part of me dies every time I
go into a store and I see something they
go can we get a phone number watching
somebody give him the phone but why
would you do that yeah I always give the
same I mine is all area coats they go
what's your phone number I'm like three
two three eight one eight two one two
five my fake email is you know it at AOL
I feel free to use any of them yeah cuz
then they all they sell all your
information and then yeah then like
you'll get a note later
oh sorry we kind of got hacked and
somebody has your social security number
now it's like well and then I should sue
you because you told me that this was
gonna what happened there's a lot of
things I'm upset with so
you